[Música]
avance para los derechos de la mujer en
nuestro continente en argentina la
cámara de diputados apruebe el proyecto
de ley de aborto hasta las 14 semanas de
gestación pero todavía debe ser
sancionado por el senado el texto que
fue impulsado por el gobierno de alberto
fernández recibió 131 votos a favor 117
en contra y 6 abstenciones tras una
sesión que se extendió 20 horas
analizamos el tema
en venezuela el consejo nacional
electoral entregó las credenciales a
diputadas y diputados electos a la
asamblea nacional tras las elecciones
legislativas el pasado 6 de diciembre
mientras que la oposición continúa con
su consulta popular no vinculante donde
preguntan a los ciudadanos si quieren un
cese del mandato de nicolás maduro
tenemos reportes de caracas
inmersa en su crisis más grave en los
últimos 30 años cuba emprende la recta
final hacia la unificación de sus dos
monedas el primero de enero de 2021
en esa fecha desaparecerá el peso cubano
convertibles moneda artificial paritaria
con el dólar y quedará como única
denominación legal el peso cubano
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 su blanco un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos la marea
verde argentina está un paso más cerca
de celebrar sus reivindicaciones con la
aprobación del proyecto de ley sobre la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
la cámara de diputados si el texto es
finalmente sancionado toda gestante
podrá acceder en el sistema de salud al
aborto legal seguro y gratuito dentro
del plazo de 14 semanas ahora el foco
está de nuevo puesto sobre el senado que
será el encargado de decidir si aprueba
esta ley ya que en 2018 rechazó un
proyecto similar veamos el informe de
marina- sardiña
resultado 131 votos afirmativos 117
negativos
atención resulta afirmativo cánticos de
aborto legal abrazos y lágrimas la marea
verde celebra con vítores del resultado
de la votación del proyecto de ley sobre
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
después de más de 20 horas de intenso
debate legislativo ahora la última
palabra para la despenalización del
aborto en argentina la tiene el senado
la sesión de diputados
los votos estarían en el senado porque
el dictamen que salió ahora con la media
sanción está hablado también con
senadores entonces por lo que dijeron
los mismos diputados tendríamos un buen
resultado también en el senado un
obstáculo que las feministas de la
campaña nacional por el derecho legal
seguro y gratuito saben que no será
fácil debido a la fuerte presión de los
grupos religiosos y conservadores en el
senado cuyos miembros representan las
provincias y por el apoyo de los
activistas anti derechos celestes algo
que refleja las divisiones que este tema
ha hecho salir a flote en argentina
donde también muchas mujeres con
pañuelos celestes se han manifestado en
contra de la ley el proyecto impulsado
por la presidencia contempla la
despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 14 del embarazo además los
profesionales que intervengan en la
interrupción del embarazo tendrán
derecho a ejercer la objeción de
conciencia' pero deberán derivar de
buena fe a la paciente a otro
profesional una cláusula que los
pañuelos verdes no aprueban no estamos
de acuerdo
de hecho nosotros creemos que eso sirve
solo para obturar en algunos lugares que
se efectivicen pero bueno seguiremos que
andamos la militancia por otra parte con
una amplia mayoría los legisladores
aprobaron el plan de los mil días de
protección integral de la mujer
embarazada hasta los tres primeros años
de infancia el feminismo argentino
confía que el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo sea una realidad
antes de fin de año
para hablar sobre el avance de este tema
en argentina quiero saludar en este
momento a ingrid beck ella es periodista
y activista feminista por el derecho al
aborto legal seguro y gratuito
ingrid gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france24 buena noche a pesar
de ser aprobado en el congreso falta
todavía como ya lo hemos visto en el
informe la sanción del senado para que
finalmente sea una ley cree que pueda
finalmente ser aprobado pasará como en
2018 y le pregunto qué es lo diferente
en esta oportunidad para que se pueda
dar ese cambio
bueno nosotros hay varias diferencias en
realidad y yo soy optimista en relación
con los resultados en el senado en
principio el hecho de que se trata de un
proyecto de ley con el bbva con la lleva
la firma del presidente de la nación es
decir es un proyecto impulsado por el
poder ejecutivo lo que hace es ordenar
un poco más a los oficialismos en ese
sentido me parece que dentro del senado
va a haber más senadores y senadoras que
te van a ver más comprometidos con él
con el voto a favor del proyecto y por
otro lado la experiencia de 2018 del
rechazo sirvió también de aprendizaje
para articular entre las dos cámaras un
proyecto que sea efectivamente posible
de ser votado en el senado y además son
dos años de construcción de avance del
movimiento de mujeres de demanda de
presión sobre la política que no me
parece menor tampoco ahora como
trabajado ustedes desde la argentina
para evitar que las mujeres acudan a los
abortos clandestinos que finalmente
atentan contra la salud
bueno en argentina existe la
interrupción legal del embarazo por
causales que está en el código penal
desde 1921 fue ratificado por la corte
suprema de justicia y hay protocolos que
funcionan así pero tratándose de un país
muy federal hay distintos gobiernos y
hay algunos que no cumplen con la ley
concretamente entonces por eso también
es que necesitamos una una ley de no
cumplen con lo establecido en el código
penal por eso necesitamos una ley para
garantizar los derechos de todas a lo
largo ya lo ancho del país se hicieron
estudios últimamente hay un estudio de
la organización internacional human
rights watch que detectó numerosos casos
de mujeres con
características que podían acceder a la
práctica según la legislación vigente y
sin embargo esa práctica fue
obstaculizada con lo cual esta ley es
absolutamente imperiosa porque tenemos
en la argentina unas 39.000
internaciones por abortos inseguros por
año por ejemplo es uno de los datos que
sí que manejamos en relación con la
práctica
ingrid gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 por
supuesto muy pendientes de lo que ocurre
en su país con respecto a este tema
continuamos en bolivia porque registra
por primera vez la unión libre de una
pareja homosexual la larga lucha de
david aruquipa y guido montaño por
lograr que su unión sea reconocida
legalmente dio sus frutos con el cis del
registro cívico que accedió a inscribir
los meses después de que un tribunal les
diera la razón
un hecho histórico
estamos en un whatsapp de más de 300
activistas a nivel nacional hay algunos
representantes que estamos acá no en
este espacio que justamente ese es el
siguiente paso sabemos que esta
situación
por eso la felicidad a medias esta
situación nos beneficia a los dos
habilitan nuestros registros 2 pero esto
no es todavía para abierto para toda la
población
el consejo nacional electoral de
venezuela crédito este viernes a los 277
diputados electos para el período
legislativo 2021 2026 quienes ganaron
sus escaños en los cuestionados comicios
del pasado 6 de diciembre cuyos
resultados no reconocen la posición y
parte de la comunidad internacional los
primeros en recibir sus credenciales
fueron los políticos más conocidos del
partido oficialista que obtuvo el 91 por
ciento de los asientos en el parlamento
las pasadas convención legislativos no
se presentó el sector de la oposición
que se agrupa bajo la figura del líder
juan guaidó este grupo opositor llamó a
boicotear los comicios por considerarlos
fraudulentos además convocó a una
consulta popular nuestra corresponsal en
caracas cervinia fernández nos da más
detalles
sí y buenas noches raúl luego realizó
una rueda de prensa el día de hoy para
animar a sus seguidores a que acudan de
manera presencial mañana a esta consulta
simbólica también esta consulta comenzó
de manera online el 7 de diciembre y
según waldo ha sido un éxito y ha dicho
que es un instrumento de lucha para
llegar hasta la comunidad internacional
y mañana se votará en 78 países lo
mencionara pueden votar en 78 países en
335 municipios del país están
habilitados tres mil puntos y siete mil
mesas para ellos también se espera que
la mayoría de personas que acudan a esta
votación sea las personas mayores que no
han podido hacerlo con las distintas
plataformas online que fueron
habilitadas para hacer esta consulta
popular brasil superó este viernes los
180 mil decesos por coronavirus mientras
que los casos confirmados superan ya los
6.8 millones en el país según informó el
ministerio de salud brasil con sus 210
millones de habitantes se mantiene así
el segundo país con más muertes por kobe
19 en el mundo después de eeuu y el
tercero con más casos después de la
unión americana e india
vamos precisamente a eeuu donde el jefe
del gabinete de la casa blanca mark
meadows pidió a stephen jan el jefe de
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de fedea que limita si esa
agencia no autoriza hoy la vacuna contra
el cob y 19 desarrollada por facer pay
un take el diario the washington post
indicó que esta amenaza ha provocado que
la fed edad haya adelantado su
calendario para dar el visto bueno a la
vacuna este 12 de diciembre por su parte
el presidente saliente de donald trump
criticó a la sda en twitter a la que
calificó como una tortuga grande vieja y
lenta e instó a sacar las malditas
vacunas ahora dejen de jugar y empiezan
a salvar vidas así escribió en su cuenta
de twitter
el sector cultural de francia queda
decepcionado después del anuncio del
gobierno de que no se relajarán las
medidas de confinamiento nacional como
estaba inicialmente planeado después de
haber previsto su reapertura para el 15
de diciembre se anunció que los museos
cines y teatros deben permanecer
cerrados ya que los contagios por kobe
19 están disminuyendo tan rápidamente
como el gobierno esperaba
soñando con volver al escenario esta
compañía de teatro de parís estuvo
ensayando durante el último mes todo en
vano ya que el lugar tendrá que
permanecer cerrado por lo menos tres
semanas más
estamos muy cansados es realmente
desalentador hace tres semanas que nos
emociones como galp a los actores están
angustiados se supone que los actores
deben estar en el escenario
entreteniendo los anuncios del gobierno
francés son otro golpe para el sector
cultural que ha expresado su frustración
en vídeos como este publicado en las
redes sociales argumentando que los
cines y teatros no son más riesgosos que
el transporte público o los centros
comerciales este cine había invertido en
nuevas películas para su reapertura y
ahora está pagando el precio es la
tercera vez este año que nos han dicho
literalmente el día antes que debemos
permanecer cerrados pero habíamos
preparado todo para los nuevos
lanzamientos
jordi sim hemos invertido un millón de
euros en películas y no podemos hacer
nada para recuperarlo
este museo de cera también se enfrenta a
más pérdidas financieras después de
prepararse para reabrir a tiempo para
navidad
habíamos esperado recibir a las familias
durante el periodo festivo
habíamos reclutado a gente cancelar la
venta de entradas es mucho trabajo y
significa que no podemos reabrir en tres
semanas a vaya por todo el final pues
viste tu gobierno fácilmente se espera
que los cines museos y teatros reabran
el 7 de enero pero la vuelta a la
normalidad parece todavía muy lejana
cuba anuncio de la unificación monetaria
a partir del primero de enero del 21
para poner fin a más de tres décadas de
circulación paralela del peso cubano y
del peso convertible la medida que
supone la primera devaluación del peso
cubano desde la revolución de 1959
elimina el peso convertible y establece
una tasa oficial única de conversión de
24 pesos por dólar veamos el informe
y 2021 con una sola moneda en
circulación desde el primero de enero
cuba eliminará el peso convertibles que
se cotizaba a un dólar y dejará solo el
peso cubano a una tasa oficial única de
24 pesos por dólar la medida largamente
esperada supone la primera devaluación
de la moneda desde la revolución de 1959
aunque menos severa de lo que se temía
así el gobierno busca simplificar el
sistema monetario y cambiario y generar
mejores condiciones comerciales para
impulsar la golpeada economía de la isla
ya se ha expresado que la tarea
ordenamiento no constituye por sí misma
la solución mágica a todos los problemas
presentes en nuestra economía
sin embargo favorecerá la creación de
las condiciones necesarias para avanzar
de manera más sólida
el principal temor frente a la reforma
es que se dispare la inflación
aunque el gobierno garantizó que habrá
medidas de contención para evitar los
precios abusivos y sanciones severas
para quienes incumplan pese a que
tendrán seis meses para cambiar sus
pesos convertibles los cubanos se
formaron largas filas para comenzar ese
proceso el anuncio del gobierno trajo
reacciones mixtas para el lugar que ésta
acepta una moneda del lugar que aceptan
otras pienso que a tener una sola moneda
o hacer más
a partir de esta semana
por qué
suben los salarios pero en realidad
si todo sube ya vimos los precios de la
corriente que son impagables al final y
la calidad de vida va a disminuir cada
vez más para amortiguar el impacto la
reforma monetaria incluirá la
quintuplicación del salario mínimo que
pasará de 1787 dólares el ajuste de las
pensiones y de eliminación de subsidios
excesivos y gratuidades indebidas
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúe con nosotros buena
noche
[Música]
en un instante